[Music]
the traffic was okay all right we're
rolling there okay I'm gonna get my
merch going here you know slow is the
commercial horse everything exactly all
right
what is your what is your real second
name I call you Mindy caste
it's just Minnie my lastly is zemerik
okay I'm gonna call you Mindy caste
that's better
all right here we go all right welcome
everybody to a new edition of this is a
really special one of ask mr. wonderful
Oh should I go cheese my watch
hold on I only wear red pants well I was
gonna say where's your little wonder you
always worry during shooting I know I
know I know I just forgot to do that
yeah
this is a nice level that's the Shemin
in the red banners like exactly a number
in banner I had to television alright
now we're back in action
Dean Bachelor owns spectacular this is
the overseas it is all right back to
where we were so this is a very very
special edition I've asked mr. wonderful
because I've got with me here Mindy
casting now you know how many casting is
she's the soup one should I forgot
you're supervising El supremo yeah sure
that works supervising casting producer
super dicey kasi producer for Shark Tank
yeah so if you want to get on Shark Tank
you're gonna run into Mindy so she
cruises all around the cities all over
America where you going next I will be
in Los Angeles in Southern California
okay then after that where do you go
then we're gonna go to Charleston and
we're gonna go to Marilyn and then New
York and then Phoenix Wow yeah I mean I
think some more cities that feel like
you're cruising all over the place
everywhere
oh so that's when you roll up in those
lineups and you show all your stuff many
looks at at first so she's the first
wall you got to get through no a lot of
people think she makes the decisions and
frankly I think she makes the decision
so if you don't get on shark tank she is
the one to blame
Mindy casting right no it's people that
are above me that make those decisions
just trying to push off criticism again
but anyway so we're gonna get into some
questions of Mindy casting all about how
it works and how the casting process
works because you know tens of thousands
of people are constantly you know
soliciting to get on Shark Tank because
it's great platform we already know that
we're going to our 12th season that's
very good that's yeah great okay now
speaking of 12 seasons there is an
individual named Aaron Marino aka alpha
M he's got like 5 plus million followers
on YouTube this guy has had his ass
kicked off shark tank not once twice
that's pretty rare right it's very rare
I think it's only a hands
or less than I've actually come back
twice right so even Mindy Cassie knows
the legend of alpha yes but after
getting his hiney booted out of there
twice this guy didn't stop he's an
incredible entrepreneur because now he's
a multi-millionaire and he's got a new
product line so I wanted to give him a
shout out to support him because he was
very nice to me recently we did a couple
of YouTube things together and he told
me about a new line of sunglasses so
here comes the pitch now this is the
shameless promotion right you're gonna
pitch I'm gonna pitch painting look this
is alpha M's new line of sunglasses
called enemy now how did it come from
the name like that he told me a stories
walking down the street you saw the sign
enamine he was thinking of sunglasses
and he put the two were together kind of
crazy right yeah all right so let me get
into the pitch itself because enemy was
created to solve you know a simple
problem to be able to offer high-quality
sunglasses and a really affordable price
you know instead of getting sick $300
price from a designer guy you can get
these enemies that are made the same way
but because they're direct-to-consumer
you save a fortune instead of 300 bucks
there are $95 really try that pair on
mindy casting whoa as a matter of fact
Erin's sorry I'm giving that pair -
Mindy classic he gets them because she
looks great them there's no question
about it these things have spring hinges
to take the sunglasses you know and make
them very very flexible hard to break
you'd have to replace them every year
they had UVA and UVB protection you'll
notice the difference check these other
look spectacular than these two what
about these you like spectacular and all
of them I'm just not bad right let's see
you look good yeah yeah I like them and
so look do you think about the sunglass
industry you've got to pay all these
people through distribution but what
alpha you know Alva M did he said okay
we sell direct you you're gonna save a
fortune so instead of 395 bucks
look you can be 100% confident they'll
suit you know if that was that a rageous
commercial I'm giving this guy and I
can't believe it
but I have to admit these are nice
aren't they I like them I like them a
lot
so look maybe I want to talk about the
casting process
there's only well I think you look the
best in these really what again yeah Oh
ridiculous
Oh so la that's wonderful three Thank
You Aaron that's very kind of you to
give me any those classes thanks Aaron
all right let's get down to business so
we're here to answer your questions
we've got tons because a lot of people
know you are coming on maybe Cassidy yes
so we got to talk a little bit about
what it takes to get on shark tank
you started this how many years ago I
started season one whoa yeah what were
you four years old I was twenty oh god
I'm 36 now so no with you 24 that's a
crowd yeah and I knew nothing about
business and so you grew so obvious I
think yeah but now now when you're going
through the process how do you make it
easier for yourself because you're
getting pissed what how many can you do
in a day our largest open call was in
Miami a couple years ago and we saw five
hundred pitches which was about one day
what do you do just blow through so it
got to a point where the actual building
was shutting down and it was like 9:00
p.m. and so we had to do group style
interviews so I lined up about 10 people
and could you you want to be fair to
everybody yeah we don't want to turn
anyone away we've never turned anyone
away I don't know can call if they show
up and we're packing up we'll get them
in real quick yeah but in the group
instance we had 10 people and I just
said give me a woman at pitch go go go
go go and then I didn't ask any
questions we just said thank you and so
they had to be really really on it yeah
so can you tell me the top three things
that you really want to see in a pitch
because it must be my numbing you're
seeing so many in one day how can you
possibly remember number one when you're
at number 500 great question we take a
lot of notes so while someone's pitching
me and there's there's an ongoing joke
in casting and I tell everyone that
pitches us we have resting pitch face
which is I am resting [ __ ] to start
but resting pitch faces when their pitch
resting [ __ ] our pitch things I
have both resting pitch face is when an
entrepreneur is pitching me in an open
call yeah and I'm taking notes and I
this deadpan look on my face and they
think oh my god she hates me I'm doing a
horrible job she doesn't like this and
so I tell everyone before they pitch
we're not gonna sit there like a bobble
head and be like uh-huh uh-huh we're
gonna actually want to hear what they're
saying and we take note are you hitting
them with questions too we asked couple
thought questions in the vein of mr.
wonderful yeah they will always ask you
know what are your sales how much have
you raised how much you invested what
have you given up you're taking those
notes th-they make it to Hollywood okay
it's because that because what we have
to do after they pitch us is we have to
go back to our producers yeah Andrey
pitch everything to them so for me to
remember one number one and number 500 I
have to take these notes and are you
videotaping everybody nothing no video
today on videotape you gotta be kidding
swear to god why not
it's just too much we don't need to
because what happens is we take the
basic notes that we needed an open call
and then if the producers are interested
in moving forward and getting more
information we have the entrepreneur
then fill out a 34 page application and
then they make it 34 pages you can get
into Harvard easier than getting on
chart and then they have to make that
video so you do you remember really when
someone says the preacher says you know
I like that it sounds interesting what
do you do remember anything about that
pitch yeah Miami or Philadelphia or
Boston wherever was Oh clay asks that
all the time okay clay will ask you know
what what was there a backstory here or
what what have you so there's a lot of
stuff that comes up so I am going to get
to the questions you're Mindy casting
for a second all right yes I just want
to say one thing that a lot of people
don't realize about Shark Tank I never
see these pictures nor does any shark
because we have rules about that so if
you stop me in the street and say I want
to tell you about my deal don't do that
because then you will never get in front
of Mindy casting do you ask them if
they've ever yep whoa vacation also have
you ever
a shark have you reached out and if they
have it's like I never got a response
where I saw Kevin and passing just asked
for a photo and then didn't pitch his
company but if they've sent you like
with mark sometimes they send out the
business plan right and he'll take a
look at it or you or Barbara whoever
I've been pitched and I keep telling you
stop stop stop yeah maybe this is a
great idea I gave it to Alex my god that
is hilarious
yeah he looks at it and if he likes it
he goes to clay which is our showrunner
producer right yep and how many people
are actually involved in bagging all the
deals that you're pushing at them
my team is 13 people total is there
another team no well just the casting
t-mister the cast on one of the 13 is
gonna see a deal before it goes on Shark
Tank right there's no way they're going
through your team yeah everyone has to
come through us they go through all of
our associates and producers and then
they come through me and then if I like
them I show them to clay and the
networks and how many pitches a year
like mm how many pictures are you gonna
get we we losing you online stop online
outreaching to companies and then open
calls we'll see Farley between 25 and 30
thousand applicants [ __ ] all right so
let's get into the quest Jones all right
by the way while we're here I just want
to do a quick pitch for this merchandise
the reason I started this merch line is
that Nancy and Kirsten can get rich okay
that's good that's good but also I want
to show I don't always wear a suit you
know with the tongs New York yeah yeah
Cole's country Cole it's called us one
of them you can go look at all the stuff
at cold hard merch calm check it out
cold hard merch beautiful t-shirts just
shows you an always dressed up in a suit
all the time well I love it because I
wore all black to match us all today
let's get at this okay we're gonna we're
gonna listen these questions and I want
to hear your answer too okay the first
one is from Heidi let's do it Heidi
Scott I've been watching the show
this [ __ ] is the best you'll ever see
I've been watching the show since season
1 when you started what's the craziest
pitch you've ever seen you've seen all
the pitches right yes what do you think
craziest this is crazy as ever aired
just so we are clear because there's
stuff that hasn't that's true that I
true I can't because it's so crazy you
can't exactly yeah crow God craziest
pitch I would have to say it's probably
one of your maybe favorites is padlock
oh that dick is your response we were
sitting backstage we all that was the
thing that shocked you yes what a stupid
I told you I would do a deal with anyone
but you
right I told exactly that's how I felt I
was really offended because and by the
way Alice took that back to the office
and he was walking around shucking
himself court unless it was sword at
SEMA the chairman like this obviously
Alex what what are you doing with that
thing so I'm testing it on wants to get
worse
you really hit your yeah it was crazy
yeah so obviously that's the crazy it's
based on just the entrepreneurs answer
and then your response because we'd
never have seen that's it I would have
to go back to season one you may
remember we had an original set that was
different little news this and that guy
that proposed a surgical implant or ear
in her ear with bluetooth and then he
didn't know how to change the batteries
so he went back for surgery and David
said to me what happens if you get in
the showers you get like electric shock
when it gets wet what a crazy eye that
was that's what I thought to myself this
whole thing isn't gonna work
this is so nuts and that was 12 years
ago and now here you know here we are
alright let's get a question here from
John I'm mr. wonderful this is John and
mine
my question is what are the steps
involved in getting onto shark tank I
understand from looking on Google and on
YouTube that you basically submit your
proposal your information if you get to
the next step you may need to provide
you know more detailed information in
the video what happens after that um you
know whether or not you're gonna move on
to the next round
John honey sweetie poop so you've come
to the right place we have Mandy casting
here you gotta answer that question this
is a guy that doesn't come to one of
your cattle calls so he's just trying to
learn how does he do it online does it
work so online see there's two E's well
there's kind of three ways to apply we
can either reach out to a company if we
see an article you can go to another
wait a sec you reach out sometimes yes
they don't come to you correct well this
is news to me yes there's so that's the
kind of the third way is we read
articles talk about keeping the Sharks
in the dark
well not the point so you see something
you really like you reach out you pitch
them I come on the show
pretty much who wouldn't come on sharks
so I'll randomly cold email someone and
that's you doing that's me and and
Ashley and and some other people that
are on the team is why and why wouldn't
someone come on sharking if they had the
opportunity I don't know sometimes they
are just not interested in being on TV
sometimes there's someone actually
emailed me back in a day and said mr.
wonderful will eviscerate me on my
evaluation and I said well then that's
perfect
listen if you have a stupid valuation I
deserve to evisceration that's the right
thing to do so don't come into the shark
tank with a stupid valuation of course
I'm going to eat you alive that's a
crazy thing that's what I'm there for
and I don't feel bad about it by the way
I think I'm doing a great job I don't
care about your feelings I care about
your money but that's interesting what's
the next way you can get on sure you can
go to an open call which we obviously
always announce through you guys and
through myself and EBC and then the
third way calls the stuff you're doing
in Miami
yes where everyone comes in and all
right [ __ ] you think that gives you
an advantage in any way to go home
that's a good question a lot of people
ask that there's no advantage it's all
level playing field I will say we can
get through hundreds of people at an
open call in one day yeah whereas our
emails our online submissions have been
backed up since August last year so it's
you haven't even gone through last
August no because we filmed in September
so we're done casting in August so they
didn't get in early enough right exactly
tell us now what's the cutoff for the
online stuff for a season what months
did you have your online picture so we
take we have those we'll start back in
August and work our way up to present
day but it takes us months to get
through those online submissions so
someone who's applying and wants to
because the 13 of you reading them every
day well that's five people doing that
whoa so all day long videos and those
pictures no it's just no videos at this
point yeah maybe when they go online
they type in their information there's a
quick blurb about their company maybe a
photo and a website and shall we call
them I mean what do you have to put in
that quick blurb to even have a chance
to get to the next level the good news
is we call a lot of people that apply
online and we just want to get to know
them a little bit more because you can
only get so much you don't know the
person's personality you don't know
anything there's Sarah is there
something I could do I'm trying to help
people who really want to get on this
show I would say throw out the numbers
in that in that blurb just say you know
we've we've raised our not raised we've
had this much money in sales within this
amount of time and then here's how I'm
different and better than XYZ so if
there's already competition or sales
he'll write sales even if they don't
have sales that's fine still really be
able to pinpoint what makes them better
and unique from anything else okay then
we might be more interested to covering
some of the three ways you've called
them which is really interesting they
come to a casting session of cattle
calls when I call it yeah up to 500
people yeah handy that's crazy and
lastly they submit online correct and
you're saying it's a level playing field
level playing field yes okay so that's
good to know if you believe in you
casting I'm not sure I do but you know
and it is all lovely
I promise and then what what I think is
name was John was asking is if there's a
if we ask you to make a video and fill
out the thirty four page application
then there's a very long process you
work with producers there's a really
long 34 pages the contracts 50 pages
there's a lot of work yeah like you need
to know what high school they went to
was the name of their dog who they dated
but we want to get to know them in their
backstory just as much as we want to get
to know what their business this is
where maybe they get a shot they do all
this works
maybe maybe and what percentage of all
that work actually gets through
oh I out of I think ten thousand pretend
potentials there's ten thousand people
doing thirty-four page applications
around there and then that's it and then
2688 me there whatever that matter oh
you are nasty like that is awful so your
chances are really small point zero one
percent I used to like you but this is
Wow well you called me a crazy chicken
yeah yeah chicken let's hear from do we
have here this looks like lastly here we
go ready Leslie mr. wonderful for the
past few years I have attended almost
every open call with Mindy and her
amazing team but I still haven't been on
Shark Tank I've used almost every trick
in the book I was funny I was emotional
dramatic but it's not made it to the
finals I must be doing something wrong
so can you share the biggest 3no knows
when it comes to pitching and the real
secret to get you on the show thank you
you are a nasty nasty woman
Leslie you three times that's ridiculous
in my defense there have been people
that applied for five for eight seasons
in a row and I only have got
all right now persistence pays off she
asked you a question what are you gonna
say the three no knows um the thing is
so I will say this before I get to the
three no nose is we don't want you to be
anything that you're not so if you cry
cry but you don't have to cry to be
funny I'm not looking for people to cry
mr. wonderful will make you cried on his
own but I mean we just want you to be
you that that's really what it is anyone
authenticity you want transparency
that's you know what what else because
she said there's got me with the top
there's no secret but I would say when
you come to come to pitch us you know
you should absolutely have passion and
energy if you're not excited about what
you're pitching my producers aren't
gonna get excited and then eventually if
they make in front of you you're not
gonna get sown in your notes me you must
in your notes may be casting have a
little I kind of liked it a one out of
four something don't lie to me the
Muslim there must be a little stars how
do you know what to pass forward okay we
pick we've passed everything forward and
then what then they decide the producers
who make way more money than I don't
know you can put your own opinion on to
anything they ask me then I might give
some insight or an opinion but for the
most part I'm just like here it's like
throwing spaghetti your Switzerland you
let even the crappy of steel in with the
good one right cuz I don't know what
they're get what they're looking forward
for you maybe they like goats coming in
and they likes the naked man and who
knows maybe we mean that's all fun so
you never know alright that's that was
an interesting one nicely but there's
not real three no no's per se but I
really don't believe it Leslie doesn't
get rejected a fourth oh great talk
about just a horrible outcomes I'm on
your side we got here this is Matt what
do you got Matt hi I'm Afra Mullins
we're about to apply for the show but I
read something about the show taking
royalties or equity in any company that
takes a deal is that true and you have
any advice or what makes an awesome
pitch
okay well let's answer the first one
eyelets the first one in season three I
wait to see the executives the show is
really a PC which is Disney it's MGM and
it's Sony yes and one day I realized
that because we were they were taking a
royalty many companies real companies
with real sales that shoulder beans
wouldn't come on Shark Tank because they
couldn't in any way give out free equity
right the deal was either a percentage
of revenue and I'm the royalty guy what
a certain loyalty swore or equity that's
their option yeah so we got we were able
to get all the lawyers from all the
companies on a phone I remember this
phone call and the roads driving when it
happened and I said them guys this isn't
working
we're not getting good companies and the
show was languishing in season three we
were changing there's an executive
change of ABC I said you got you got to
decide are you in this business of
making television or do you want to be
venture capitalist like I am right and
the rumor of this you know who knows
that this is legend or whatever the
story I heard was this went all the way
up to Eiger on the ABCs oh I didn't know
that have you said we are not in the
venture capital business I don't the
store not nice speculation but let's do
this and make great television let the
Sharks take the risks with their own
money and in season four we got rid of
it and look what happened the show
exploded its season because we've got
such great deals you found great
companies they were willing to come on
didn't have to give up equity they
didn't get there yeah and that what
happened there changed everything it did
and it was the bane of my existence for
the first three years because I was the
one that had to handle the contract and
explain to people the gray area of it
helped it was I was on the phone like at
least 78 hours a day with different
people just saying well this is when it
happens and this is when it might not
and everything so when it got rid of it
I was like this is the best day ever
but we still get asked that question to
this day because every kind of to
everyone still thinks clearly this seal
we don't mess things so it is so the
only equity you give up is if you
actually make a deal in the deal closes
whether it's equity or there was a deal
with you
yeah yeah and that guy sharp the other
you know big question people ask me is
it really your own money and yeah I had
millions of dollars in shark tank deals
over the last 12 years and thankfully
many of them have been very successful
made back money this is good he also
asked you what makes a great pitch there
must be something you think of energy
and passion knowing your numbers and
being able to really kind of separate
what makes you different and unique from
XYZ and then a little bit about your
backstory and what's at stake so if you
are a single dad or a single mom and
you've had to deplete your 401k or move
in with your parents your kids college
fund is gone gone we want to know those
things so those are kind of that's an
extra of three and a half or four tips I
would add one other that I think over
this 10 years 12 years now get your
story out in 90 seconds or less tell me
what the product is don't ramble on
that's a Led Zeppelin song I want to
hear concise pitch I want to know what
the hell it is you got yeah you got to
show it to me right away because if
you're just me and ring down the road
and I don't know what you're there for
I get bored right away and then I want
to eviscerate you for wasting my time
like that is really important yes
absolutely you tell them that we do we
actually have an open call I tell them
we want it's a very short amount of time
it's a one-minute pitch when they come
to us and then we ask a couple follow-up
questions then they say it's good you
need to be able to tell us what makes
you different and better and then a
little bit about your backstory but I
don't watch this here in 1982 I was born
in Winslow man I don't start there just
I say bullet-pointed here's what here's
3/4 facts and then done but I want to
know what the product is that I'm being
potentially going to invest in that's
what I want to know yes good question
for math there let's see what what else
we got here all right this one is from
Natalie
hi mr. wonderful is Natasha from
Edmonton Alberta I need to know where
did you get those awesome t-shirts Kevin
that's wonderful
well that's hasha I'm glad you asked
it's another chance for me to pitch my
fantastic merchandise
this is cold hard merch and it's a whole
bunch of new t-shirts was kind of mr.
wonderful sayings on them I think that's
great but really it's trying to get me
out of the soup thing all the time I
really have tired of where you sit all
the time I want to have another uniform
so it's my own merch and I'm trying to
make Nancy and Kirsten work for me some
dough they get a piece of the action
they're always whining they want more
well this is the way they can do it so
this is Karstens idea again in the merch
business well I think they look don't
you like them I do like well you are oh
hold on you don't have to worry because
I have right here yes this is community
casting cold hard merch right here no
extra charge many yes we're just getting
into it now right Shirelles hear from
you
hi mr. wonderful my name is Sorrell and
my question is what would it take for
you to invest in a company that is just
in developing stages just an idea state
of a company was no sells or anything to
prove itself just a fantastic idea what
kind of things are you looking for what
kind of things you'd be excited for and
what kind of advice would you give them
you know Cheryl when you have no sales
and it's just a concept and we've seen
lots of deals like that yeah well in the
early years because we couldn't get
companies all real and we had the turbo
based if somebody came in with a turkey
baster with a battery strapped to it and
said this is a turbo based right that's
why I said we're screwed like that but I
mean sure LDS or that question is you'd
have to convince me that I'm investing
in you because you don't even have any
say
I don't like it that much because I
prefer that you've got a little more
advanced and you prove that the product
had demand I love it when products
actually go to market and people buy
them and suggest changes to them and
they keep using them and so you rarely
would invest in a prototype then you
know I never say never but I'd rather
have sales that way I can charge a
royalty and get my money back no
basically but you know Rosalie it's a
mr. wonder it's so true though you know
after all these years I hear all these
other thing I have to in my own defence
all the Sharks are ripping off my
structures now if you noticed that I
have a lot of like lorries doing a lot
more and I'm sending her an invoice you
know instead of going to school she
learns to mr. wonderful that's what
happens we're all learning things for
mr. wonderful oh it's so true there's
truth in advertising that's why they
call me mr. wonderful but I think the
shark tank journey involves every year
don't you you start you're the one that
goes out there yeah you find all those
deals and I've noticed lately they're
getting bigger
yes and they're coming in with more
sales and there have their valuations
are crazy big yeah look at blue Lynn
remember that leg up so blue leg do you
remember blue I use blue land yes I want
to do Irish out to blue land yeah you
reached oh yeah you're the one that
found me yes you gotta swear to God Kim
Kardashian to come to visit because she
all she was tweeting about it the night
it aired about blue blood blue and she
was like is this legit I just ordered
some and then I think you and me and
Mark we all gone and the shark tank and
we're all a kid any time you want to
come visit shark tank come on out that
reminds me I went to New York last week
and basically shot for blue landed
commercial
oh my god I saw it was and they said to
me look we want you kneeling by a toilet
cleaning I said I'm ready King mine I'm
not gonna do that that's me
Kevin it's brilliant it was great she
was Sarah was really cheap she was there
she watched her iframe being made she's
really hardcore yes I'm mr. wonderful
from shark tank when blue land asked me
to clean a toilet on TV I said are you
joking but here I am because blue lady
is serious about saving you
stop paying for wasteful plastic bottles
with blue land you only need to buy one
easily clean anything around your house
your fault
portraits of your ancestors and it - oh
it's habit you're set for life
and so am I because I get a royalty get
your kit now at blue ENCOM smells like a
deal yeah I'm really happy with that
company thank you for finding them of
course yeah yeah that's gonna be huge
everybody my family's using it yeah you
know my daughter loves it she's in
Brooklyn all she's telling all the
friends about it it is really easy and
it looks terrific
it's beautiful yes you know your
plastics are becoming very negative
people like that yeah so look we've
learned a lot today and I you know it's
we've never really brought Mimi casting
out trotted her out to meet her because
if you're not getting on Shark Tank I
don't care what anybody says she's the
reason so when you run into her you let
her know and I really know what's going
on here maybe casting is the first step
in the process and she must like what I
don't believe are you Mindy casting is
you must say something on there I really
like this you don't do it oh you're
lying you're lying I just know that come
on when you see a great one you must say
something good about it I mean I think I
feel like if it's a great when it speaks
for itself
oh my pitch it declares such a
politician anyways thank you so you know
we got to do this before we go yeah put
on listen up put these on okay
and get your shadow for Aaron yeah alpha
yeah baby
enemy sunglasses you look spectacular so
do you that's fantastic thanks everybody
till next time and remember you want to
get a shark tank get to know Mindy
casting she's the one bye-bye